If you think psychology is boring, then we've
got news for you, you couldn't be more wrong.
This wild and intriguing branch of science
is filled with all kinds of wacky facts and
some of them will blow your socks right off.
So strap in because we're about to take you
on a rollercoaster ride straight into the
human brain.
1.Bravery cells have been found at the hippocampus.
Scientists working at Uppsala University in
Sweden have found out something amazing about
the human hippocampus.
They've discovered that there are certain
specific cells in the hippocampus that actually
determine how brave we are.
So, the next time you work up the courage
to ask someone out or to go skydiving, you
can thank your trusty bravery cells.
2.We will probably not freak out if aliens ever
come to earth.
Hollywood loves to focus on what could go
wrong if aliens ever came to earth.
These movies often end up in massive battles
where the faith of the entire world is at
stake.
But researchers at Arizona State University
have discovered that real everyday people
actually have a much more optimistic approach
to alien life.
In fact, they've determined that people would
probably be pretty happy about meeting a new
life-form from outer space.
3.Teen love is real after all and it can impact
us deeply.
You've probably heard of the old saying "there's
no such thing as teen love".
This stems from the belief that teenagers
are not mature enough to feel real love and
what they experience is just their hormones
acting up.
But researchers at Arizona State University
have been taking this phenomenon very seriously;
they found that teen love is actually so strong
and emotionally impactful that it affects
mental health and even future relationships.
Your highschool crush was true love after
all.
4.The human brain has a much larger capacity
than we ever thought.
How many gigs of data does an average brain
hold?
Well scientists thought that they had the
answer until a very interesting discovery
was made a few years back.
Researchers at the University of California
and others have determined that our brains
have a capacity 10 times larger than previously
thought.
This means that our brains can hold roughly
the entire internet.
5.Young adults are the most stressed-out people
on earth.
It turns out that Millennials actually have
a pretty good reason for complaining so much.
According to a survey conducted by the American
Psychological Association, those aged 18 to
35 reported the highest amounts of stress,
more than any other age group.
Money and finances were the biggest causes
for stress across all generations.
6.Saffron might just be the best antidepressant
ever.
Today, people are extremely wary of big pharmaceutical
companies prescribing antidepressants and
other medication that could do more harm than
good.
But according to a number of new studies,
the most effective antidepressants might have
been under our noses the whole time.
Yes, we're talking about saffron and research
has shown that it's just as effective as pharmaceuticals
and has no side effects.
7.Were only capable of being close to about
150 people.
The age of social media has opened us up to
an entire world of potential friends where
everyone can be connected.
At least that's the theory, but psychologists
know that according to something called Dunbar's
number, the maximum amount of friends our
brains can handle is about 150.
This was confirmed by recent studies which
even took into account the recent rise of
social media.
Even after all these years, Dunbar's number
seems to hold true.
8.Money can buy happiness...
Kind of.
You've probably heard it repeated a million
times "money can't buy happiness".
Well, researchers from Purdue University and
the University of Virginia might have a thing
or two to say about that; when it comes to
happiness, their research has shown that it
only takes about $75,000 a year for emotional
well-being.
Boost it up to $95,000 and you won't desire
any more income.
Anything above that and there's no real increase
in happiness.
If you enjoyed this video.
Please like and subscribe to see more content
from Psych2Go.
Thanks for watching!